good afternoon this is quick take i'm
madison mills now 2021 is just wrapping
up but we're already looking ahead to
the political battlefield for next year
stacey abrams has thrown her name into
the hat for one of georgia's senate
seats but the battle for that seat isn't
just a matter of democrats versus
republicans this election cycle here
just to fill us in on the state of play
is bloomberg news's atlanta bureau chief
brett pulley brett welcome to quick take
and thank you for being here tell me
what we know so far about what's going
on in georgia with this election and how
purdue is coming into play here as well
well there are they are really off to
the races here uh as you indicated
stacey abrams announced last week
what was expected widely expected that
she would indeed seek the
democratic nomination and as that's
expected to happen and and she will
arrive in the general election and then
as a result of that
former senator david perdue who lost
earlier this year to
john ossoff in the u.s senate race has
now announced that he will face the
current governor brian kemp in a primary
race
so that promises to really set up a
really tough inter-party battle
here in the state of georgia president
trump has made it clear that
he will likely support uh purdue and in
fact issued a statement today in that
effect and of course uh ever since the
presidential election last year when
georgia proved so pivotal
the former president has been a big big
vocal critic
of the current governor brian kemp
so but purdue lost that senate election
already correct so what are his chances
here given that georgia's already had
the chance to vote him in and didn't do
it
well it's an interesting point but what
uh what purdue and his allies are seeing
and
and others around the party who are
indicating their support for this is
that they've taken a look
and come to the conclusion that the
current governor brian kemp will not do
well against stacey abrams in a general
election
and they believe that david perdue will
fare better and you know look it's quite
clear uh from david perdue's statement
today that he's basing this campaign on
the big big trump story that the
election
uh was was taken away from him and that
somehow something different should have
happened in georgia so that's kind of
the fight that they're preparing to
fight it it promises to be you know
pretty nasty not only in that primary
but also you know as you've indicated
we're talking about
stacey abrams who's whose
uh profile
and
and and recognition nationally as a
result of her uh
of her uh voter voting initiatives
has really really exploded in recent
months
extremely popular candidate
and
a really a
hot issue
when we talk about running on the basis
of again last the last election uh not
being uh fair uh so it's it promises to
be really nasty and you know one of the
things that's interesting about it is
that brian kemp and david perdue have
really been close allies they come from
kind of the same wing of the state party
and in fact uh
uh they were together as recently as
this summer uh at the state convention
and uh so it's uh
it things are things are splitting up
fast in the stadium sure sure it seems
like just another indication of kind of
the pre and post-trump uh republican
party and divisions within that i do
want to listen quickly to uh former u.s
senator david perdue's announcement
let's let's listen into that and then
we'll get your reaction
i'm david perdue
i'm running for governor to make sure
stacey abrams is never governor of
georgia
make no mistake abrams will smile lie
and cheat to transform georgia
into her radical vision of a state that
would look more like california or new
york to fight back we simply have to be
united
unfortunately today we are divided and
brian kemp and brad rappensberger are to
blame
i mean brett he he makes that nastiness
you mentioned really clear in that
announcement really going after stacy
abrams
given what you said that georgia you
know voted for biden in the last
presidential election i mean how likely
is it that they
don't go with abrams in the
gov gubernatorial election as well
yeah well look i think this thing is
going to depend on if indeed purdue is
successful
in the primary and kemp is not going to
be a pushover
but if he's successful it's going to
depend on whether or not they can
convince voters
that indeed somehow
things have been handled unfairly in the
past you know to that and in fact one of
the things in that clip that you just
played was david perdue also criticizing
the current secretary of state brad
raffensberger right who we know uh
infamously received a phone call
from the president
about the election outcome and has been
another target of the former presidents
and there is a trump-backed candidate
also seeking that office as secretary of
state running against raffensberger so
there are few around the state uh
trump-backed candidates who are lining
up
to
to defeat
to defeat
others from the republican party in the
primary
brett the last time we talked we were
chatting about the election laws in
georgia to what extent could those come
into play with any sort of result we
might get from this upcoming
election well i don't know that anything
is going to change you know from the
legislature's vote uh last fall i think
it was uh and what we'll have to see is
how those things play out right you know
like for example you may recall that one
of the issues was that you can't hand
water out right they've heard different
interpretations well you can't hand
water out uh that that's you know in the
you know the course of campaigning water
that's branded or things like that so i
don't know exactly how it plays so
things like that i guess we'll be
watching closely to see what kind of
impact it has and of course
uh in terms of those who are in the
business of getting the vote out i'm
sure that they'll uh
you know that they'll be uh
focused on what the rule changes are as
well
and just in terms of what voters might
be thinking about i know that inflation
is a huge issue where you are in atlanta
with a 7.9 percent price hike in the
area how could that impact uh what
voters are thinking about as they they
go to the ballot box
yeah i mean look we have some of the
highest prices you're right uh in the
country i mean we're trending higher
than just about anyone else so you know
you have to think that that that it's a
factor look
it it's kind of rare when economic
issues are not factors sure and then
there are some other you know some other
big issues here particularly in the
atlanta area as it relates to crime
and those kinds of things uh but uh but
i would say that uh that the that the
economy will be paramount and as we know
the current president's approval ratings
are are
not so great right now largely as a
result of that
right right and of course that could
also play into the election results
final question for you brett what are
you going to be monitoring uh looking
ahead just in terms of any predictions
we may get about this election outcome
and how well uh stacey abrams could or
could not do
well you know this is the thing i mean
look this is kind of going to be a test
of certainly how influential the former
president
trump is
and it's going to be a big test of
just how much
power stacy abrams does have when it
comes to statewide contests because let
us not forget
senator ralphiel wore not warnock who
also
won in a runoff earlier this year has to
face re-election next year because his
seat was
just a two-year seat because he was
replacing someone who retired early so
that race is going to be after again
against a trump-backed candidate the
former
university of georgia and nfl football
star herschel walker so uh so
it's uh
there are a lot of there i think there
are a number of factors to watch here
and it you know it makes it quite quite
clear that georgia once again is going
to be pivotal uh in this midterm
election certainly a state to watch
especially as we look to what the future
of american politics as a whole is going
to be looking like bloomberg news
atlanta bureau chief brett pulley really
appreciate you joining us as always
thank you so much we're going to
continue our coverage right here on
quick take throughout the day so please
stick with us for more but for now i'm
madison mills in new york
[Music]